They say that you should set a thief to catch a thief as no one else understands
the criminal mind better.
Perhaps the most shiny example of this idiom is vidoc the man who is now hailed
as the father of modern criminology. He went from a life of crime,
spent either on the run or in the prisons of France to establishing a national
detective police force that served as the model for skull yard and others
followed it.
He employed proto forensic techniques,
such as ballistics and casting foot impressions. When he left, the four seat,
started his own agency and became the world's first privat eye Vido goes against
many of the tropes we have of the stereotypical detective.
He was far from brilliant and his success was more down to him being methodical
and persuasive, hit a violent streak and was chiefly motivated by money.
He made plenty of enemies during his career, as you are about to see,
and his life was filled with almost as many failures as it was successes.
Most of the information surrounding the detectives early years comes straight
from the horse's mouth courtesy of the memoirs of vidoc the autobiography that
he published with the help of a ghost writer in 1828.
So with that in mind,
do feel free to take what we get from it with a generous helping of assault.
Eugene Franco vidoc was born in the city of harass and the paid hall department
in Northern France on July the 23rd, 1775.
He was the third of seven children of Nicholas Fran. Okay.
Prosperous baker and his wife het, Fran SW.
He was actually born in the house next to the one where Maximilian Robert Pierre
was born 16 years prior. The Vidor family lived in a rough area.
Ofra called the platter Monds comes subsequently.
The young Eugene got into scraps in an early age. Fortunately for him,
Vidar had a large strong constitution.
And by the age of eight,
he already bragged about being the terror of the children in the neighborhood.
He also took up fencing when he was young and by the age of 13,
he was prodigious with the foil vid off's life of crime.
It started as a teenager and his first target was his own Emily business.
The youth worked for his father's bakery by making deliveries around town and w
ould dip into the till money to spend at the pub.
It was also around this time that again,
making the acquaintances of the city's local black guards,
cons and other various villains, when his father discovered this,
he began locking the till,
but the enterprising vidoc forged the key with the help of a blacksmith.
So when the senior vidoc again, put an end to his sons scheme,
the offspring began simply stealing items and pawing them.
This led to the first arrest and a few days in Borday the local
jail. Instead of setting in straight,
this experience convinced vidoc to go for the one big score and then leave town.
He broke into the bakery with the help of a friends and have scolded with 2000
Franks.
He built the money and half with his accomplished and each went there separate
ways.
Early on in his life on the run, Vidak learns a harsh but necessary lesson.
There is always a bigger fish.
He might have considered himself a successful criminal,
but he was still naive in the ways of the world.
While traveling through Belgium, you secure passage on a ship,
he met an stranger who took him to a house full of friendly,
beautiful women that he was drugged up.
And he woke up the next morning on the darks half naked with only a few crowns
to his name vidoc was forced to take employment where he could find it.
And so he joined a troop of performance.
He was treated miserably beaten regularly, and he was given scraps for food.
His appearance became so wretched that at one point he was asked to pretend to
be a Savage island, cannibal who feasted on raw flesh.
This prompted him to leave and join a group of puppet tears. The,
at this new gig didn't last very long because he was kicked out for making eyes
at his employer's wife. From there,
he joins up with a group of traveling pedals led by one father God art.
When opportunity arose vidoc returns home to us where his father,
if a eventually forgave him,
he enlisted in the army and joined the B on regimens where his reputation and
his tempo would often lead to fights after six months Vida the nickname reckless
after engaging in 15 duals and killing two men in 1792,
France ended combat with Austria in the war of the first coalition.
Vidor took part in several battles and was pro to degre a deer,
but deserted after receiving a court martial for hitting an officer,
he joins the 11th Chas under a different BA.
Although his desertion was discovered a captain interceded on his behalf and was
forgiven after being shot in the leg. The 18 year old vidoc,
he was returned to Fido years.
As a young adult seemed to have been mostly divided between the prison cell,
the army on the rare occasions that he was free of both.
He typically engaged in romantic Tris or felonies ventures.
He even married once, but the relationship added rather quickly,
his adventures took him to Brussels where he presented himself as Mo Reau.
Since Eugene Vida was once again wanted for desertion in 1795,
he joins the flying army and been came a Haar captain.
He caught the eye of an elderly widowed barer who bequeathed him a generous sum
that enabled vidoc to live it up in Paris. For some time, after a few months,
the money was gone and vidoc was back in prison. Peter,
he discovered a new talent forgery and with the eight of a lover named Francine
L escaped several times, but was always recaptured soon after just five years.
Vidoc had been imprisoned in numerous places not to mention once being Shanghai
in Rotterdam and having a short stint as a private tier reported Dutch ship
In 1800 day, 25 year old vidoc escaped prison and made his way back home.
He found out that his father died the previous yet.
He wanted to stay with his mother,
but was recognized and he had to flee again in raw.
He assumed the identity of a merchant named blonde Del.
He was successful for a couple of years and planned to send for his mother
before being discovered.
And once more having to go on the run time and time again,
Vidar tried to start a new life in a new city,
but it seemed that everywhere he went his past would soon catch up with him in
1809.
Vidar found himself in familiar surroundings after being arrested and sent to
prison. And doubtedly, he could have escaped.
He could have used a disguise or bribed the guards or even climb to the walls.
And eventually vidoc, would've been a free man. Once again, however,
he had grown very weary of prison escapes and the fleeting liberties they
provided. He offered to put his experience and reputation to good use,
and he became a prison informant.
AISE chief named Jean Henry accepted the deal and relocated vidoc to LaForce
prison in Paris. It didn't take long for the prisoner to prove his worth.
Vidoc made the acquaintance of frost Tamel,
a criminal who was part of a gang of prolific robbers,
although already imprisoned.
It would not be long before Tamel was released due to lack of evidence or
witnesses.
Vidoc managed to gain his confidence enough that the felon revealed to him,
the residents of his mistres sure enough police acted,
rage and found enough stolen merchandise to sentence Torm to eight years.
Not only that,
but the criminal still trusted Vida and gave him enough information to get his
accomplice as arrested as well. For 21 months,
vidoc applied his informant services between the walls of the prison.
Eventually honorary realized that he would be more useful on the outsiders.
He would be able to infiltrate many criminal establishment instead of just
waiting for the criminals to come to him.
They secured his release and made it look like just another escape
For the first time in a long while Ji Vidar could walk the streets as himself
without having to worry that the first officer who recognized him would try to
arrest him. He wasn't gonna be a free man though.
Vidak was a secret agent in the service of the state.
His goal was to gather information that resulted in the prevention of crime and
the capture of felons.
His first color was a counter fitter named watchin in his autobiography,
Vido pointed out so that this was the beginning of a problem that dot him his
entire time on the force, as well as into his career. As,
as a private detective, all the other offices,
they were jealous of his success and relished the opportunity to see him fail
under the old adage of two heads, uh, better than one.
The doc brought in some help and organized an informal unit called the security
brigade to aid in his crime, fighting.
It consisted mostly of other reformed criminals like himself back then Francis
police force. It was may mainly divided into, there was the police pate,
which was the secret police that handled covert operations and uncovered
intrigues against the state. And then there was the standard man in the street,
uniformed police that dealt with common crimes like theft matter and fraught
crucially Vidak convinced his superiors that his agents should avoid the
uniform.
And instead Don plain clothes and disguises to help them infiltrate areas
that were otherwise off limits to police.
This group was a success less than a year after it passed the sorta that's the
French word for it officially became a unit of plane codes,
detectives under the purview of the prefecture of police of Paris with vidoc as
its first chief. Fortunately for him,
the man at the top Napoleon was also a key recognizer of Francis police force.
He established the prefecture of police in 18 hundreds and also increased the
numbers and his respons of the Jeanmarie who up until that point,
functioned mainly as a semi militarized force dispatched to keep the peace in
rural areas of the country,
seemingly Bon apart approved of OCS revolutionary approach to crime fighting a
year later,
further expanded the cert into the state security service known as the cert NA.
Now vidoc trained all of his agents, personally, me,
even when he had a few dozen men under him,
he still enjoyed dressing up like a beggar and hitting the streets for some
undercover work.
His unit was responsible for hundreds of arrests and reportedly decreased the
crime rate in Paris by up to 40%,
according to criminologists John Phillip stead in 1817,
the threat made 811 arrests, including 341 thieves,
46 fors,
14 escaped prisoners and 15 assassins 1817 turned out to be AB particularly
fruitful year for Vidar because he also received a full pardon for his past
crimes from king Louis, the 18 up until that point,
although he was a superior officer with the Paris police force Vidak was still
technically a wanted criminal.
The following decade proved to be a more turbulent time for the policemen,
both personally and professionally. He married again in 1820,
but his wife passed away four years later and his mother died shortly after
that.
And his professional life doc started to lose the support of his superiors Jo on
retire. And the next police chief mark was not a fan of the cert
ley.
The police prefect who obtained a pardon for vid dog also had to retire after
failing to prevent the assassination of Charles Fe and duke of Barry. Finally,
the king himself died and was succeeded by Charles the 10th.
Vid dog always maintains that the antipathy showed to him by other members of
the police force was due to end the of his success. Well,
there was certainly plenty of that.
There was also resentment that a criminal would advance so high in the ranks
without facing any serious consequences for his illicit past. At the same time,
vidoc became quite wealthy and famous during his career in law enforcement.
He rubbed elbows with the Perian elites like Victor Hugo,
and made enough money to start his own paper company.
There were also UN substantiated rumors that he continued his criminal
activities, but now he just did it with the help of the law. By 1827,
vidoc had had one too many confrontations with his new boss after 18 years on
the force, the 52 year old tendered, his resignation to mark Duci.
The police chief was happy to be rid of him. Although bizarrely,
he appointed as his successor. Another Excon convict named bar.
The Coco Laur Vidak might have been a Shrew criminal and a pioneering detective,
but he was not a very good businessman.
It did not take long before his company went bankrupt, but on the bride side,
the time off fell out him to put down his memoirs by 1831 DCY was gone.
And the new police defect a Guay invited vidoc back on the force.
He was chief of the CTA once again, but his position was short lift.
Perhaps it was merely a symptom of the instability felt in France during the
July monarchy, or maybe due to the color outbreak that was ravaging the country.
But people showed little indulgence towards vidoc and his group of ex convicts.
The few instances occurred in short succession where agents of the CTA were
accused of acting as provocateurs against rats.
And some were even indicat in a theft.
The units actions became harder and harder to justify.
And by the end of 1832 vidoc was once again, quarterly invited to resign.
He did so by sighting concern for the health of his third wife, who, by the way,
it was also cousin following his departure.
The CTA was purged of anyone who had a criminal record, even for minor offenses.
The former agents didn't have to look for a new job in 1833,
vidoc founded Liber bureau dere, more per coms,
office of information for businesses. Paul,
for my French clients could access vids database of profiles on crooks
and frauds should the need arise.
They could also hire his agents to conduct personal investigations and
surveillance into their interests, which often have nothing to do with business.
And instead pertained to private matters such as adultery or finances,
business information bureaus, they already existed,
but because of extra investigation services,
many consider vidoc new endeavor to constitute the world's first private
detective agency. Once again, he predominantly had Excon convicts. Many of them,
former agents of the cot, since he had already trained them.
If the rest of the police force had contempt of a vidoc before now,
they loathed him.
Many were not pleased with the idea of an extra judicial group investigating in
crimes for the highest bid of accusations were thrown now more than ever that
Vidar and his detectives operated in a gray area of the law at best and did not
shy away from a few illegalities to finish the job.
You can't argue with the results though, and the agency it flourished at first.
However,
his quarrels with the true police force led to several arrests and seizures.
The new prefect Gabrielle der was definitely not a fan of VI dark,
and always looked for a new chance to crush its business.
That opportunity while it arrived in 1842,
when the prefect ordered a massive raid on the agency,
which resulted in vidoc arrest, he stood accused of fraud and illegal arrest.
Eventually vidoc was free again, but not before spending a 11 months in prison.
When he was released,
he was 67 years old and it became pretty clear to him that his best days were
far behind him. He spent the rest of his life, mostly outta the limelight,
and he died in 1857.
Vidoc laid the grounds work for the calling of the detective, but we,
it clear that he was never a Sherlock Holmes type character.
He did not fit our image of the typical brilliant detective who gives brain
summations in a room full of suspects and revels in how the murderer did it
while chewing, oh, let pipe, if anything,
he was more of a successful psychologist than he was a detective.
He knew how to use his appearance, his reputation,
and his attitude to get other criminals, to trust him and to confide in him.
Another dull that practical ACE up his sleeve was his obsession with keeping
accurate and detailed records and all the criminals that he encountered.
But doc often boasted of having an incredible memory,
but he knew that his agents were not as good it early in its infancy.
The CTE began making index cards for the rogues in Paris listing the physical
appearance, distinguishing traits, prior convictions, modus, opera,
and any other information that might prove useful the system. It was primitive,
but it worked. It came in real handy. Later when Viox started as private agency,
the CTE made use of it for decades until it was over and improved by AFA.
Batalion. This being said,
let's not completely detract from the men's accomplishments.
This vidoc put his talents to good use in ways very few other crime fighters had
done up until that point.
His had at least a handful of cases that would serve rather well for a Sunday
afternoon crime show on one occasion,
Vido meant early one morning with a suspected thief named hot hot,
the last to looked tired, his clothes were wet and his boots were muddy.
Clearly this was a man who had had a busy night fi doc excused himself,
and went to inquire about burglaries that had happened the night before he
arrived at a crime scene and noticed a pair of footprints,
which made him think of hot hots, muddy boots. He had an agent fetched,
some plaster of Paris. He made a cast of the prince,
which he then match to the criminals boots, hot, hot confessed.
And he was sent to the gal.
Another time vidoc investigated the notorious murder of Countess. Isabel de ay,
everyone assumed our husband had shot her,
but the detective relied on a primitive form of ballistics to prove the count
innocence. He had the doctor extract the bullet from the count's body,
something he had to do in secret because it was irregular for that time.
And he showed that the ball was too large to fit in counter A's dualling pistol.
Instead Vidak matched it to the weapon of the counters lover who then confessed.
Eugene Vidak might be long gone, but his legacy,
it lives on his literal friends, IM mortalized him in his books.
BZA based several characters on him, chief among them,
the criminal mastermind V tri in his semi work li Victor Hugo drew
inspiration for both his main characters,
the convicts and the policeman from the dual life of the dark.
The detective himself left behind quite a complimentary account of his exploits
in the form of his memoir.
But perhaps no other tribute is quite as fitting as the vidoc society.
Back in September, 1993, criminal experts met for lunch.
William Fleischer was a retired Philadelphia police officer and FBI agent.
Frank Bender was a forensic sculptor and Richard Walter was a criminal
psychologist. They started talking sharpens.
The discussion eventually turned to cold cases.
The three men realize that their knowledge and experience could prove to be an
asset to a detective who is stuck looking for that one little clue that could
lead to a break in the case. Not only that,
but they knew plenty of other people who could also lend their expertise. Thus,
the vidoc society was born.
The organization meets once a month that the union league of Philadelphia,
it has ag permanent members. One for each year that vidoc lived.
However many others have joined as special members by invitation.
Only they include forensic scientists, law enforcement officers, prosecutors,
profilers, medical examiners,
and psychologists seldom will you find more experts on crime gathered of the
same roof.
The members have lunch and listened to an investigator who is there to present a
murder case. He is stumped.
He's out of leads and the trail has gone called for years.
He is hoping that the people there will have some extra insight members of the
vidoc society offer guidance and advice. And in certain cases,
even travel to the office's jurisdiction to take a more hands on approach with
the invest investigation. Over the years,
the society has concentrated its efforts on cold cases from small or underfunded
police precincts, where its efforts would have the largest impact.
The society first tasted success in March of 1991,
the family of a murder victim named Huey Cox from little rock Arkansas believed
that the man charged with crime was innocent. The IANS agreed.
Two of them provided X about testimony at the trial and the case was dismissed
almost 30 years apart since then,
the vidoc society helped solve cases like the Arizona canal murders and family
annihilated, John list. The group stresses that it doesn't want FAL glory.
And indeed often there is none.
The society limits that not enough investigators are actually aware of their
services and would like a bit more at tension if only so that they can work more
cases and continue the detective legacy of Eugene the doc.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did give us a thumbs up below,
let us know what you thought of it in the comment section,
also subscribe and hit that notification bell. Why not also,
I've got another channel. If you didn't know about it, maybe you want to,
it's called top tens. I'm gonna link that below and as always,
thank you for watching.